la deuxième vague est arrivée et elle
frappe la russie de plein fouet 1200
hospitalisation par jour à moscou
seulement
l'hôpital s'est remplie depuis que j'ai
été admis il ya dix jours 10 nguema
l'con l'ancien député et analyste
politique a contracté la co vide et
documente ses soins sur sa page facebook
[Musique]
quatorze mille nouveaux cas par jour en
russie et le plateau est encore loin
d'être atteint
bien qu'il soit un ami du kremlin
markova du mal à s'expliquer pourquoi
les mesures sanitaires ne sont pas plus
sévères car de l'aveu même du sous
ministre de la santé
90 % des lits prévus pour la coved sont
déjà occupés en russie en régions la
situation est critique et le personnel
épuisé ses employés de la santé est
manifeste pour de meilleurs salaires et
pour dénoncer les conditions de travail
il nous faut en moyenne 45 minutes pour
répondre au téléphone cet ambulancier de
la ville de samarra et parfois trois
jours pour aller chercher un patient
imaginez sept autres ambulanciers que
nous avons joué à saint pétersbourg dit
que le nombre de décès a aussi atteint
des sommets mais demain relativement bas
puisque la russie a choisi de rapporter
seulement ceux dont la cause principale
est la coved 19 et ce qui l'inquiète le
plus c'est la désinvolture qu'il observe
chez les gens comme si de rien n'était
les consignes en ville du moins sont à
moitié respecter une certaine fatigue
s'est installée
d'où la décision des autorités de moscou
de sévir davantage contre les dissidents
avec des inspections surprises comme
celle ci dans les transports en commun
ou encore des amendes salées pour les
commerçants mais pas question de les
fermer comme au printemps de la médecin
en chef du pays et elle précise que les
grands théâtres comme le bolchoï cette
fois resteront ouverts tout comme les
cafés les restaurants les cinémas et les
gymnases l'économie russe a déjà vous
faire
et même si cette deuxième vague
s'annonce pire que la première les
autorités préfèrent punir les
insouciants que d'opter pour un
confinement général si thammarat
intéresse courage au canada